[Musik]
ja wir kommen bei philo cast jörg schön
dass du da bist hallo masse unsere
heutige sendung gibt und das thema des
internets wie das internet selbst da
wäre natürlich jetzt die frage was ist
das internet also vom von der
wortbedeutung kann man sagen internet
meint einfach dass zwischen netzen
internet als internat einisch zwischen
und nicht eben netz als es eine struktur
der verbindung von informationen könnte
man sagen ja okay und könntest du
vielleicht auch auf den unterschied
zwischen intra und internet gehen weil
es gab ja schon sehr früh intranets im
militär oder ähnlich genau also das
internet wie wir es heute kennen es aus
am intranet hervorgegangen intranet ist
ein netz was abgekapselt es was nicht
mit anderen netzen kommuniziert oder in
verbindung steht und aus seinem recht
regionalen lokalen intranet einem
abgeschlossenen netz ist dann immer mehr
ein weitverzweigtes netz entstanden was
dann eben heutzutage internet genannt
wird
ja also da kommen wir zum thema der
eigenschaften des internet zu sprechen
es scheint ja ein unterschied zum
intranet sehr offen zu sein gibt es
andere tendenzen die das internet
irgendwie mit sich bringt ja als du hast
schon einen wichtigen punkt angesprochen
offenheit weitläufigkeit und
begrenztheit prinzipielle unbegrenzt
zeit und die tendenz äußeres neues zu
integrieren und aufzunehmen also man
muss sich das vorstellen wie so ein
großes pilzgeflecht was sich immer
weiter ausdehnt und eben nirgendwo halt
macht das ist einerseits eine sehr
positive sache aber natürlich auch in
der gewissen hinsicht eine
problematische mal wo es sind die
grenzen das internet schluckt alles und
ist sie ist die information jetzt
wirklich nötig oder sollten wir sie
nicht vielleicht besser draußen lassen
also selektierung genau das thema
stichwort informationsflut ich mache
jetzt oben rechts noch mal ein link
rhein zum zu den themen sendung im
seminar über informationen dass es
eigentlich ist was es ist ein
informations geflecht
was innen sich selbst jetzt mal nicht
die struktur enthält wichtiges und
weniger wichtigem zu unterscheiden das
ist eine problematische dimension des
internets wird nicht qualitativ
gewichtet mich interessiert auch so ein
bisschen die frage ob das internet an
sich intelligent ist und dazu gehören ja
bestimmte eigenschaften wie man kann
irgendwas erkennen man kann etwas
begreifen verstehen
man kann vernetzen was das internet ja
kann aber auch irgendwie empfinden und
vor allem auch selektieren würdest du
also sagen das internet hat ist
intelligente oder wie inwiefern ist es
intelligent also man kann jetzt
zumindest eine gewisse analogie von
einer form von denken sprechen im
internet nämlich das vernetzte denken
oder das assoziieren de denken und zwar
wird das realisiert durch die struktur
des hyper links oder das hypertext das
genau über text bedeutet dass bestimmte
begriffe informationen verwiesen sind an
ähnliche verwandte informationen das
kennt man alles aus der wikipedia
struktur wenn man da so blau unterlegte
begriffe hat und das ist total hilfreich
weil wird sich marco diesen begriff
kannte ich auch nicht jetzt glücklich
mal da drauf und werde unmittelbar
direkt verlinkt und das ist eben auch
noch so ein charakteristikum des
internets unmittelbar obwohl sie ein
medium genau medium heißt ja eigentlich
vermittlung und eigentlich bedeutet
medialität dass es mehrere schritte
bedarf um wohin zu kommen aber das
internet ist eben das medium was
unmittelbar ist also da die vermittlung
die unmittelbar ist bisschen paradox
scheinbar aber man könnte auch sagen das
internet ist nicht nur irgendein mediums
und ist es das medium schlechthin der
inbegriff des mediums darauf hat robert
dreyfuss auf den wir in der letzten
sitzung eingangs nicht nach oben rechts
in den kram hingewiesen es ist also
wirklich der inbegriff des mediums und
zwar deswegen weil es die bedingungen
schafft die grundlage schafft um
überhaupt zu vermitteln das ist die
grundstruktur der vermittlung ja also
sehr interessant ist
paradoxon dennoch scheint es irgendwie
logisch
ja wir haben jetzt auch den unterschied
gemacht dass das internet tendenzen zum
denken hat irgendwie denkstrukturen hat
wie sieht es denn damit aus wie fern
kann uns das internet beim denken helfen
können da kurz was sagen also ist es
hilfreich oder ja also wie immer gibt es
zwei seiten also einmal ist es total
hilfreich weil wir von einem begriff auf
die nächsten springen können begriffs
hopping oder griff springen eben und uns
sowie eine weltkarte ganz neue gebiete
erschließen können
nur ist dieses erschließen nicht ganz
analytisch also wir wissen dann manchmal
gar nicht am anfang wo wir am ende
rauskommen wir erkunden das einfach mal
recht spielerisch springen hüpfen
also ich würde sagen es ist nicht
unbedingt das analytische denken dass
zergliedern soll das assoziieren des
großräumigen holistischen also groß
zusammenhängenden erkunden von
informationen und das ist natürlich auch
problematisch man kann sich verlieren im
internet man kann sich nicht mehr
konzentrieren
so geht es jedem wenn man mal bei
wikipedia ist man landet am ende wohl
ganz andere ist weil so viel
interessantes über links sich hier
anbieten gepflegt zu werden
und da fällt mir nun kommen da einen
sozusagen damals beim fernsehen ist es
ja so gewesen dass man sich sehr bald
hat man konnte nicht wirklich
das waren 26 programme oder irgendwas
konnte man sich da entscheiden aber das
war es auch
das internet hat jetzt die funktionen
geboten sich wirklich zu entscheiden hey
das will ich und ich bin auf der suche
nach neuen informationen genau ein guter
punkt also das internet macht dem nutzer
die nutzerin sehr autonom selbst
bestimmt welche informationen er oder
sie bekommen möchte wie du richtig sagt
ist wir hatten vielleicht durchaus 100
programme manchmal satellitenfernsehen
usw
aber wir waren darin dann doch
angewiesen auf die jeweilige sendung und
wenn man jetzt das nur vergleich mit
youtube ich kann ganz gezielt nach
interessen schwerpunkten suchen und
finden was auf mein interesse jetzt
zugeschnitten ist das problem dabei ist
dann aber wieder dass man durch diese
algorithmen die eine bestimmte dinge
wieder empfehlen total in einer blase
bleiben genau das sind problem also die
automatischen suchvorschläge die auch
auf künstlichen ansätzen passieren
die führen dazu dass wenn man einmal
sich was interessiert hat immer wieder
mit verwandten themen konfrontiert wird
im sinne eines angebots und das hängt
natürlich auch mit dem hypertext
zusammen aber das führt dazu dass wir
dann nicht mehr offen sind unter
umständen für andere gegenteilige
perspektiven und wieder richtig sagt das
sind sondern mit der metapher der blase
wir können nicht mehr außerhalb dieser
blase herausschauen und verstricken uns
vielleicht auch dann etwas na das hat
sowas von ideologie auch an sich ja also
voll gut ich haben wir so dass
strukturelle vom internet haben wir
jetzt beschrieben und analysiert oder ja
gesagt jetzt gut werben es analysiert
und die frage nach etwas lebens nach
höherem
ist es denn ein grundbedürfnis das
internet wir ja also vielleicht war das
ja beispiele für ja es ist man könnte
wirklich sagen es ist zu einem neuen
grundbedürfnis geworden wie fließend
wasser elektrizität licht und wärme
es sind in einer wohnung vor 50 jahren
war elektrizität tolles gemüt wenn man
das hatte in der wohnung oder vor 100
jahren
kann ja gerade die elektrifizierung
wärme und fließend wasser das war
natürlich auch was tolles aber
mittlerweile ist es so
mittlerweile wollen wir das internet
auch noch haben wie so ein wasserhahn
aus dem irgend was rauskommt oder strom
und das zeigt einfach das internet ist
nicht nur was modulares eine
zusatzoption die wir da zu suchen
sondern das internet hat eine
grundstruktur eine basis auf der
überhaupt dann erst etwas anderes
ansetzen kann und deswegen könnte man
das internet auch als eine art
transzendentale struktur zeigen als die
bedingung der möglichkeit von medialität
im konkreten sind also man kann ja sagen
dass wasser wasser strom wärme so ein
bisschen zu die bedingungen der
möglichkeit gegeben haben dass wir eine
kultur aufbauen und eine neue kultur
genau sind die grundkoordinaten die
grundbausteine grundstrukturen damit
darauf was neues entstehen kann und
genau so ist im internet auch die ganzen
start-ups und so weiter und so fort die
klinken sich in das internet nutzen das
visionen fruchtbaren boden auf denen sie
was sehen und und involvieren sich dort
und nutzen das als so eine plattform
eine basis auf der dann neues auftreten
kann
und ist es wirklich was neues weil wir
sind ja auch auf der suche nach dem
begriff der digitalität der seiner
digitalen kultur einer dritten natur ist
es was neues würdest du sagen
unterschied zu wasser strom
ich würde schon sagen ich würde das
wirklich als eine neuentwicklung ansehen
die uns trägt gesamte welt in unsere
informationskultur revolutioniert ich
bin der meinung das internet ist eine
revolution und zwar eben deswegen weil
es etwas ist was wählt weidner world
wide web sagt er schon es umspannt die
ganze welt macht auch vor der welt nicht
halt andere sterne antreten alles kann
damit einbezogen werden und es macht uns
unabhängig von raum und zeit
es ist grundsätzlich egal von wo aus wir
ins internet gehen solange wir natürlich
strom haben es gibt eine gewisse
abhängen
kalt von anderen konstruktion aber es
ist völlig irrelevant wo wir das tun und
wir erreichen die informationen in
sekundenbruchteilen und wir können uns
informationen von anderen teilen der
welt holen ohne gewisse privilegien dazu
genießen zu müssen das heißt das
internet hat auch eine gewisse
demokratische struktur
es hat aber auch wiederum schaffen zeit
eine gewisse anarchische struktur thema
darknet thema datenklau hecking trojaner
aber auch eben urheberschutz rechte
filesharer und so weiter und so fort das
wird uns eben zu dieser frage wo muss
man diesen grenzenlosen netz grenzen
setzen und diese grenzen können ganz
verschiedener hinsicht gesetzt werden
zum einen systemischen theologisch also
in dem sinne dass wir uns zurechtfinden
müssen in der flut dieser informationen
wir müssen selektieren und das kann man
auch noch machen indem man gewisse
grenzen setzt also suchmaschinen werden
ganz wichtig suchalgorithmen man kann
künstliche neuronale netze auf das
internet ansetzen und dann natürlich
auch moralische grenzen also wo hört auf
mit der meinungsfreiheit kann ich im
internet alles sagen was ich will
man muss ja bedenken dass man das häufig
auch anonym sagen kann also eine weitere
spannende frage ist auch die nach
unserer identität
es gibt zwar so was wie eine ip adresse
die man herausfinden kann aber in der ip
adresse ist eine nummer und wer sich
genau dahinter verbirgt das weiß man
halt nicht wobei ein anderer punkt
nochmals ganz kurzen willkommen so
wieder dran
wir hatten das auch im seminar gesagt
das internet kann man so beschreiben
dass es durchaus eine form von
individualisierung vor lässt nämlich wir
sind das nachdem wir suchen unsere
gesammelten suchanfragen
charakterisieren uns als individuen
ziemlich gut und hier stellt sich dann
wieder die ethische frage wer sagen wir
die daten und was macht der oder die mit
uns daten ja ja danke eine sache die
jetzt noch anfügen möchte zu deinem
redefluss der äußerst interessant war
ist nämlich die frage nach der realität
also wir hatten individualität
das und anonymität dass das möglich ist
aber was mit realität und virtualität
also das sind zwei begriffe auf die wir
in der nächsten sitzung natürlich auch
einkommen zu sprechen kommt das wirst du
noch sagen aber virtualität ist ein
interessanter begriff der so was wie
auch künstliche wählten bezeichnet zb
avatare wenn man sich pseudonyme gibt
wenn man in computerspielen und auch in
chatforen eine neue identität annehmen
sondern ist die frage inwiefern ist die
identität wirklich und dann ist man sehr
schnell geneigt zu sagen sie ist
überhaupt nicht friedlich sie ist nur
virtuell oder illusionär und das sehe
ich anders also ich würde sagen selbst
virtuelle identitäten also identitäten
die jetzt nicht in unserem normalen
leben jetzt physikalisch leiblich
verkörpert auftreten haben eine eigene
realität weil wir damit auch etwas
bewirken also wieder thema causa alle
kräfte und wir können damit auch geld
machen wir können in computerspielen
seltene gegenstände zu euro ist oder
bitcoins oder was auch immer machen und
das zeigt mir deshalb nicht nur eine
bloße virtuelle währung ist sondern das
ist eine währung die eine eigene
realität hat dafür gut für das letzte
wäre die frage nach verleitet das
internet zum bösen ja das böse ist
natürlich ein spannendes thema und
natürlich auch ein sehr starker begriff
ich würde jetzt erst mal allgemein nur
vom unmoralischen sprechen und auch hier
denke ich kann man sagen das internet
verleitet zum guten zu moralischen aber
auch natürlich zum moralischen handelns
und jetzt ist die spannende frage
inwiefern ist im internet neue formen
des moralisch guten und neue formen des
unmoralischen oder moralisch bösen gibt
gut sicherlich in dem sinne dass man
demokratischer ist dass man viel mehr
menschen partizipieren lässt dass man
zum beispiel auch gewisse
abstimmungen vornehmen lässt oder
gewisse aufrufe über das internet machen
kann an den ddr aus dem sich viele leute
anschließen können
das ist eine möglichkeit der
demokratischen partizipation moralisch
problematisch ist es sicherlich im
internet wenn man das darknet sich
anschaut dann dass man eben häufig seine
identität nicht richtig preisgeben muss
und dass man vielleicht auch im internet
sich verlieren kann denn und tiefen des
netzes
das ist dann auch eine große
herausforderung an den nutzer eine
medienkompetenz zu entwickeln und
deswegen würde ich auch den kritikern
des internets immer entgegenhalten das
internet an sich ist weder gut noch böse
noch schlecht noch erstmal neutrale die
möglichkeit eine chance es kommt auf was
wir daraus machen und deswegen braucht
halt jeder und jede die ins internet
gehen eine medienkompetenz sowie eben
jeder und jede die eine kreissäge oder
ein hammer bedient eine gewisse
kompetenz mit diesem werkzeug benötigt
uns hat man sich auf den daumen
ja damit ist eigentlich auch schon die
frage beantwortet ich ein bisschen ans
publikum richten wollte wer ist schuld
mensch oder medium hast du ein gewisser
weise beantwortet vielleicht haben die
zuhörer auch noch irgendwelche punkte
die sie in den kommentaren auf youtube
reinschreiben konnten oder uns
persönlich anschreiben über die melder
verlinkt ist
vielen dank ist auf jeden fall sehr
spannend die nächste sitzung das nächste
thema ist virtualität und ich freue mich
drauf sagt es war schön vielen dank ja
danke marcel